над але мені вони то за але ви ж
ru нудьгував опади, а то сотня рокки
bluetoth 6 new
до і вам приділяти своїй академії бали
шляху у 1990 іншому уроці коли стегно
поділася academia
в'ячеслава бруховець каму вдалося і ін
бути справною лабораторією для
зрощування національні еліти та академія
тримай і всю плату і сьогодні по всій
україні за зараз відро дружиною академії а
панамою за грубість на тебе
для завдань на всі україни-руси
борозенкою гуманітарного знання основних
темряви я кіпр і внесла
академія в українській жити а шерсть
твоїх випускники
відсік вантаж вигляд немає слів україни
з балика разом я міг і лямки
evanda в dc чудовисько він їсть і ніс листи
у своєї батьківщини на своєму робітнику відвести в
українському suspect і циклу будинок зданий немає
сильних
висновки області людей а канонічні
свободи води так сам сьогодні у шириться
по всій Україні раз отримував сам із
вас все разом сикстин вибуху
так уже президент Києво-Могилянської
менш розвиненою наукою робом все а будете
око і вийшов зі стіни нижчих
університеті малий лянка
c. зростання
ти їй україни і мон яскрава старша
видно б нам огляд на широкий вигляд
українські конституції
аджі сьогодні ми так вже тебе u20
уроки
українські конституції кривим оголюється
якими ви коли та пункти шляхів йди
вперед повнота
хочуть стати треки шкіряних марі право на
віслюку каскад у тебе місту я можу янка
за газ причиною фарбування вищого світла в
краї не
стаття 54 шкіри моє право на свободу
творчо
про ціну на місто а могли янка
c за вас занепалі будуть створі не на
екрані в краї не на жаль для самари
за ті та креативності та статтям
яко на мою думку дірку рушити на вулиці
е40 чверть з таки сказано
проти мого права набитий чому вона
досить стрічці тут шкіру стоп обличчя і моя
права наша біди роботи без у нього тут я
труп смаження
а сьогодні я до чого вибори ти душа по
важливу і серйозну українську конституцію
у всіх часто руйнується і наше лихо в тому
щоб моєму не брешу за позовом
душам варошу ось сильному за ти знову за
світловий ми стандартам та конституцію
pro-t базовий тип носіїв конституції
не приділяв і до сьогодні до кінця не
втратити все можна вкласти і край
їх чоловіки вас ти викликав ви зайшли сором і
свою до рабина свою батьківщину або стоять і
бохуме
український європа ефективності я з
Пукіна на вашому ринку в альма-матер дала
вам потрібні весь зад і типом hat and fast
і для життя якийсь дозволить вам точно
ставок і успішних я нудьги нато мій самий
шлях не нашої України ми загоріти
топовий франко
захарів беркуту ми перемогли нашим думати
kimlo вам нашу воду you
і дружною носіться тепер ноти та тіні
правове держави я кейсі рівне порід
закону
я просто магії в рамках встановлених
піст і шляхи назад капелюх диму і залякаєш
на кому ех ви знайду смоли і
тому ми читаємо у вас на
тримали сушіння у бізнесі у рамочку
software
приходить відсотки
рожево душі ти навколо цілий вірш
врубати україну європейську
демократичну правову
успішну економічну державу слова вам
зла україни